great thank you Richard for the kind
introduction should I sit down and talk
maybe it's easier for me to flip is that
ok ok all right today I'll talk about
the the China startup dream because i'm
sure most of you are very interested in
entrepreneurship and entrepreneurship me
in asia and the hottest area of
entrepreneurship has to be China because
China is ever-changing story it's a
changing story of growth so one thing
you can be certain about China is that
it will change and people talk about it
all the time every government that goes
on since nineteen forty nine has been
talking about reforms and it's been
reforming for the last 60 70 years still
reforming so this is a very evolving
story so today I'll share some of my
experiences starting a company investing
company in China okay the story starts
from here ah 1999 is when I graduated
with W degree and I did my research work
in CIS which is right next door so I'm
very familiar with this area over here
right after Stanford I went back to
China to start a company and given the
time of the year was nineteen ninety
nine and the thing to do as a graduate
from Stanford is to start a company so I
remember back in the time inside the
graduating class of nineteen ninety nine
about twenty percent of the student body
either started a company or join a
start-up so it was for those who those
of you who remember the times it was a
very very exciting times I see remember
in 1999 attending a lot of lectures
similar to what you guys are listening
to hearing experiences from
entrepreneurs from investor from sin
hero sharing experiences how to start a
company how to get investment how to
develop how to market and I remember
hearing um the two of the lectures I
remember the most was a one from
Tom Siebel one of the founders Oracle
which also started simple systems and
another lecture in the GSB of steve jobs
after at best one he gave the first
structure in Stanford after he returned
to Apple so hearing them sharing their
experiences I think that's one thing
that struck me is that they're just
ordinary people and they weren't
extraordinary I mean in in the class or
in there when they start out starting
the company's we're very very normal
very ordinary but when they what they
have done is extraordinary so that's one
thing that struck me is that from these
lectures from these experiences that's
what's being shared is that if they can
do something great from their ordinary
beginnings that anyone can and so can i
I think that's one thing that I got most
out of my Stanford experience is that
this confidence that anybody could
change the world so that's that's one
thing that perhaps after this lecture
after sharing my experiences hopefully
you get that same energy and same belief
of same confidence that if I if I can do
it so can you to do something
extraordinary so I went back to China
that was the difference from most of the
the teams that started companies here is
that I felt that the Internet boom was
just starting in the United States but I
believe that this is going to be global
then everyone in the world won't be
probably will participate in this
internet revolution so after when after
going back to China to study the market
with a couple of my classmates we
decided that China was almost ripe to
have to get into this internet boom so
we went back to China as you can see
this we started out this building this
is after we got our funding that we
moved into this building this
number 66 on the 90 xi road which shows
that buildings because there's two other
Stanford companies inside one is cisco
not one sun sun microsystems so we chose
that building because we felt that it
must have some good luck to it okay
being close to these two to Stanford
funded companies so we started a company
in China we raised our funding from
Goldman Sachs KKR and Joe Howe capital
from New York that we ended up raising
15 million dollars from these two rounds
seriously and Sears be out of these
three funds and in 1999 you know that
the time is that everyone was talking
about to you new Academy nobody really
cared about revenues or profits so ended
up that we spent 15 million dollars
acquire a lot of users and we were very
good at it so we're talking to investors
that about if we don't get any revenue
or if we just spend all this investments
on user acquisitions and product
development what's going to happen to us
in the future and our investors were
telling us that it's a new economy and
we don't have to worry about it and all
we have to do is just keep on doing what
we do best which is acquire users and we
can go public on NASDAQ so we're very
excited and we're ready to go on NASDAQ
and weird because Goldman Sachs was are
seriously investor so they were talking
to let the banking people were talking
to us about listening then everybody
knew they do sell that the market
crashed and that I feel hopes were gone
and goma was telling us that we're not
going to get any more funding and we
gotta sell the company so we sold the
company in September of two thousand
that was only a little over a year from
the beginning of the company to to the
time of acquisition and that time the
acquisition the a lot of companies want
to acquire us
including many of the US companies
because we were the fourth largest
website in China in China in terms of
traffic and the website is very young
but in terms traffic it was very very
high traffic website the site was a
community-based site it was called
community back there today we'll call it
social network but this term wasn't even
coined yet we ended up selling to
another one of the listed companies from
China it was called so who it was the
second largest internet property in
China at the time so they hired us and I
was in so who for a year and a half but
because I was an entrepreneur by heart
that of course I left the company to
start my second venture which richard
has introduced which listed on NASDAQ
after two and a half to about two and a
half years from beginning to IPO which
was in the space or mobile internet it
was very early age or at these times for
mobile internet wasn't even called
mobile internet back then it was called
wireless VA as value-added services I
ringtones java games if you remember
those things coloring pack tones etc and
combed rome which was the second company
it was the largest in china in that
field so sharing some of the experiences
from 1999 is that there was lots of
obstacles to entrepreneurship in china
the first of all is that china just
joined the WTO but still many industries
were closed to foreign as well as
private capital including the telecom
industry internet was considered a part
of the telecom industry and especially
foreign capital was was a no-no in this
in this area and angel investing venture
capital private equity was non-existent
now this isn't that the concept of
investing in private companies were very
foreign very strange in China in in 1999
so most of the most companies had to do
was to
borrow money to start companies so
lending added from banks or from
individuals was the primary source of
funding for most startups in China it
was really difficult to attract quality
employees because most people want to
work for 400 500 foreign companies or
they want to work for state-owned
enterprises because most people most of
the employees the qualified employees
want stability instead of the sort of
like if you are entrepreneur that they
don't know that whether how long you can
last so they'd rather not work for
start-up and also the lack of
infrastructure variety development ISPs
internet service providers for almost
non-existent the data centers were very
very crude I remember that when we
starting our website we have the
building was very very very bad
condition building and that was the
center of internet for China and the
elevators doesn't even work so have to
carry the servers on the stairs I was
Carrie with the engineers so we have to
have strong muscles as network
administrators again there was a huge
information asymmetry across the Pacific
so most I have to bring a lot of books
on java programming PHP my sequel etc to
to back to China because even those
texts on internet programming was
lacking so most of the employees don't
even know how how to make work of the
internet technologies so these were a
lot of the obstacles for entrepreneurs
in China back in 1999 the most the
biggest obstacle toward entrepreneurship
especially in the internet field is that
foreign capitals not allowed in the
channel internet space ah that was a big
problem because we raised our capital
from the United States right our angel
investor was from Silicon Valley RVC
goldman sachs kicking a partnership fund
okk re etc there are home foreign
capital so that was a problem this the
sign is it was called the Ministry of
Information industries it was it was the
governing body of the telecom industry
as well as Internet and the Minister has
said that foreign capital is not allowed
specifically so we had to cope with the
obstacles first of all we didn't
necessarily want to raise foreign
capital but we raise foreign capital out
of necessity because there was no
venture capital in China or privately in
China back in 99 and I was very lacking
so most of the little then against there
was two types of entrepreneurs in china
in the internet space one is called the
returnees or in Chinese the the word is
called return a sea turtles highway the
other other group of entrepreneurs was
the locals or the Aborigines or whatever
these local entrepreneurs and inch high
in Chinese they were called to be a
these men lowly land turtles worthy it's
a casa which is a high-end you know the
sea turtles which very vague you know
returning sea turtles Lisa the local
turtle small local Turtles I was talking
to the Giovanni which is the the founder
of for 360 also a public company very
very big internet guy I was eating lunch
with him the other day and he was
talking to me saying that you know back
in the days you guys raised so much
capital you paid the employees so much
and you approach them so many people and
you're making it really difficult for us
because we cannot raise capital Joey 044
mr. Joe that because he doesn't speak
English he went to a local university
and he doesn't have access to send your
road or to other foreign capital that it
was very difficult for them so they had
really have to poo strap and scrap to to
make ends meet as an entrepreneur so
most of the Capitals were raised by
these returnee entrepreneurs because
they speak very good English and there
was one exception of these local
entrepreneurs or the true beer which he
raised a lot of capital ah although he
never went in the United States for
schooling but he did he did speak very
good English his name is my Union Jack
Ma the reasons that he used to be
English teacher so he was only one of
the locals who could raise all the money
otherwise all my had a scrap and they
have a succeed on their own even a pony
ma of ten cent which everybody knows
that he's there they are the biggest
internet property in China today and he
could not get funny at all he got about
250 thousand dollars from IDG and I was
about all the venture capitalist God and
so he he always wanted to sell the
company because he could not make ends
meet he could not pay his employees back
in the time when we were raised about 15
million dollars and this guy raised
about 250,000 so that was a time so
racing foreign capital was out of
necessity we found talented hires
directly from top universities I
remember going to chi moi and almost
poached their entire computer science
department all the students almost
almost half am worked for our startup
company and allowed allow them just
skipped classes and it just worked for
us because we paid them very very well
and almost like full-time employees we
used information asymmetry as an
advantage because ok so i thirsted all
they wanted to work it like I so we use
are these began yeah so why don't these
guys want to work it because it worries
so they went to go in school so we
actually we started out complete with
almost wouldn't happen our staff are
part-timers question okay solutely squid
ways they cannot work with SOS or
foreign companies so they work for us in
part-time but ended up they liked us so
much that they skipped a lot of classes
they work almost as full time looking
for us so ended up the the director of
the the computer science department
actually contacted us had a meeting with
us saying that we cannot do this they
found that their classrooms are being
emptied out and they heard of this
company right outside chiwa uses all the
other students but it's a good thing
that up because chinua is very selective
highly selective University in China so
the kids who go into there are very
smart so they learn very quickly how the
program the internet technology etc so
it worked out very very well so we use
the information asymmetry as an
advantage because we argue attorneys so
we know a lot of the the heat
technologies and the business models
from the US and where she's bringing
back to China and a lot of the locals
don't know about it and not much we can
do about infrastructure in volume except
to wait for the wave to come and it did
come so China has built massively roll
out of these internet as well as
wireless internet infrastructures the
solution we had for foreign capital is
not unique okay most of the companies
went public on in the US I'll use this
structure is called the VI e structure
variable interest entities if you invest
in Chinese adrs or the the little
chinese companies in the us's they all
uses the VI e structure which means that
in order to bypass the rule made by the
Ministry of Information industries site
so you have to separate the licence
holder from the investment or the
ownership so
there's the unsure company which holds
all the licenses which does the
operation of the internet business in
China and there's the offshore vehicle
which holds on the investment so the
offshore includes foreign investors and
the end the founders of the companies
and the unsure is a hundred percent
owned by the founders which is a
domestic team so so these two are
entities do not have any ownership
binding and they're controlled only by
contractual agreements and according to
the US GAAP and also the rules by the
SEC they recognize is that the VI e
structure is ok for this thing in the US
this is a typical structure although
this the SEC sometimes come up with the
challenge you read in the news they said
ah yeah a structure is not okay and they
they then the the accounting firms work
with them after a while they say it's
okay again or they say it's not okay and
the Chinese government sometimes said
it's not okay then they work with them
and they said it's okay again so is this
VI structure it's a temporary solution
and this sort of it's like a band-aid
it's not a perfect solution but it sort
of works out for the full time being and
the goal for most of the companies the
start of a company's in China for a very
long time was to IPO on nasdaq or NYC
but Nasdaq was more popular in the early
days in the around the 2,000 early parts
of the last decade but now my eye sees
becoming more popular because they're
doing better job and attracting
high-tech companies so control which is
my second company Alibaba Jean JD ding
dong baidu and etcetera etcetera many
many of the companies were listed in the
US and that was that was a goal
otherwise being acquired is another exit
for most of the companies
but things change a lot in 2015 today
like I said in the beginning China is a
evolving story and things change a lot
in just last half a year so today I
think the red remaining part of my
lecture is to share with you what
happened in the last couple of years
first of all there's plenty of funding
sources in China I believe there's more
funding sources in China than there are
here in Silicon Valley all the
International vc's all the International
PE funds have set up shops in China and
they have hired locally or either
locally or returnees to fill up their
shops and many domestic shafts have
grown to dominate the investment space
and domestic investments actually
outpaced for an investment in China
today and as I start up in China
remember I said before that you have to
speak English to be able to raise
capital now our view investment
PowerPoint the pizza plan has been
written in Chinese to show that you're
very local if you if you show up to vc
with english this is fine you'll be
thrown out because they feel that you're
not local at all so things have changed
change a lot in the funding sources the
information chasm has been totally
filled and returnees have no information
on advantage and they talk about you
heard about the copy to china about how
a lot of this business model seen in in
the united states when they become
popular they're being copied over china
today there's more entrepreneurs in
China than they are in the United States
so all the business models all of the
everything that can be copied is copied
whether it's popular or not so the joke
is then when y SI y combinator has a
demo day a lot of these entrepreneurs in
china they they actually stay late at
night it'll go to sleep they watched
watch it live
live broadcast a tweeter pictures video
and we'll have a new company get
featured like just in a couple weeks a
copycat comes up China so the demo day
for 44 y combinator is a big event so
China is forced to innovate white
because there's nothing the copy you
have to innovate you have to come up
with something new because every sector
every niche is totally filled government
is very very Pro entrepreneurship this
government President Xi Jinping and
Premier Li Keqiang it's very very Pro
entrepreneurship it's using resources to
promote entrepreneurship innovation them
very unprecedent way never before has
China been so pro entrepreneurship
because you know back in the old days
people talk about in the Chairman Mao's
age that entrepreneurship is being
distend then be an entrepreneur it's
capitalism right with tongue shopping
it's opening up the the country with
reforms it's allowing market economy but
never before that the government is so
proficient so prob entrepreneurship it's
sometimes people say that it's scary how
how much they're promoting this in China
the trend is that everyone is becoming
an entrepreneur in this day and age I
can say that China has many many more
entrepreneurs then the silk valley or
the United States in in total so high
estimate I guess about in the United
States right now currently entrepreneurs
is about maybe a few hundred thousand
entrepreneurs in the United States but
in China is way more than a million
perhaps there's a few milli in the
coming coming years of entrepreneurs if
you talk to young people everywhere in
China they're talking about starting
companies if you go to universities
they talk about starting companies it's
it's amazing how everyone has this
entrepreneurial dream remember before I
said it's very hard to recruit people to
work in a start-up companies now you
have another problem that your employees
want to start up companies take what do
we this is a picture of the premiere of
the new government Premier Li Keqiang
and he has his key message during the
four for his administration it's a
tyrant wrong year one room ecology which
translation into English is that mass
entrepreneurship and innovation everyone
knows that entrepreneurship is belongs
to a minority right usually that a few
of the people once struck out once start
something you want to enter the brave
new world that's entrepreneurship right
usually it's a it's a it's something
doing something different it's a
minority thing it's not mainstream bunny
China its mass entrepreneurship meaning
that it's mainstream to be an
entrepreneur so vast number of people
are starting companies that's perhaps a
lot of emotion be starting companies
right there they're not ready they're
not prepared they're not you will fit to
be an entrepreneur but that doesn't stop
them starting companies and the
government is promoting that they're
saying that entrepreneurship should be
for everyone and you're finding
entrepreneurship in many different
places if you look at this this is a the
broadcast into it's a new news story
that in the other farms then these farm
ladies are studying because the food and
which is the the Women's Association of
the of the county is the holding of
seminars teaching these women to start
companies
sorry goods and this is it promoted as a
news news story so all the government's
the provincial government the
municipalities have are ordered to
promote entrepreneurship it's amazing
how many incubators are starting up and
how many entrepreneurial contest or held
by various ministries so many ministries
are holy on these entrepreneurial
contest one currently the major
entrepreneurial contest was held by the
Department of Human Resources Ministry
of Human Resources zhengzhou boo and
they're holding a contest
entrepreneurial contest like the
TechCrunch so like the TechCrunch type
of entrepreneur contest in all over the
provinces including provinces like gansu
ningxia or scenes young you know these
provinces which is I almost desert oh
there's no almost nobody there and
they're order to hold these contents so
they're there even these provinces with
very few people they are holding these
entrepreneurial contents so in all the
cities all the towns all the
municipalities are promoting
entrepreneurship there's incubators
everywhere even I'm building an
incubator in my hometown you see on
which is the the government is giving me
a resources of a huge building very low
rent if I can fill it up the my mic API
is to to make this place a booming with
entrepreneurs that's all I have to do
the government will give me this
building with furniture fully furnished
ability with very little low-rent much
lower than the given the local rate just
so that I can promote entrepreneurship
insead because that was my hometown and
also the hometown President Xi Jinping
so also the the mirror is very keen on
this so the ones who build make sure
that she n is not lacking behind in
entrepreneurship
even the Education Department an
education ministry having issued orders
to all the universities in China last
year they have the issue the order
finally wins yeah saying that if any
student in your universities want to
start a company the universities have to
allow them to suspend their education
and the code start a company meaning
that they can come back any time to
finish their studies you have to let
them go if they want to go just let them
go and start a company and make it and
keep their school records so for example
take a sabbatical so they can come back
any time to finish their studies I
thought you usually only stand for all
outlets right but most universities
don't but in China the ministry is
making sure that every University is
doing that and just a few weeks ago the
ministry have each in the new order
saying that the university students
starting companies will be counted
toward their credits too good for
graduation now you know the government
in China is very serious I'm promoting
entrepreneurship I don't think Stanford
allows that right no you gotta do
something there if you if you suspend
your education just take a leave you
don't get credit you don't care to
credit no in China you do yeah you could
do kind of credit for taking a leave and
start a company so now you know how how
things are are working so things have
changed a lot in just this half a year
equity investments red hot in private
and secondary markets the stock boom
recently have ignited the country and
everyone's investing as they're in
primary market or a secondary market I
believe the effects are swimming over to
foreign markets because including myself
I'm coming over here to seven cavalli to
invest in startups here the reason is
because the valuation here is just so
cheap compared to comparable companies
in China everything everyone heard about
the housing prices right in the in the
Bay Area being being increased by
the Chinese spires of these houses well
there's a huge gap between the the
prices of houses and companies right
they say that uh the price you pay for a
house in the United States is the price
you pay for a bathroom in Beijing that's
that's tight about the housing price
different differences and the same thing
with startup companies is that you look
at these companies Wow it has great
technology great product the valuation
is so cheap compared to the comparable
companies in China so what happens is
that a lot of the VCS and your
investor's funds are all coming to
Silicon Valley to invest in a very big
way because they feel that things here
just so cheap so i believe the bubbly
fact is actually spilling over so prices
here it's going to move up because of
the bubbly effect of China the company
valuations have skyrocketed many
companies got rid of the VI e structure
to list back in the Chinese stock
exchanges so this is happening remember
before in the first part of my lecture
that the goal of the startup companies
to list in the United States an ass tank
in NYC now no way for the companies who
already have the VI structures there
they have a huge headache Oh child
thinking of ways to get rid of these for
investors before for an investor our
friends now for investors are enemy
because that's the obstacle to Lissie
inch in the Chinese stock market so they
have to buy out these foreign investors
so a lot of example talk to the foreign
investors like look you know we're not
doing very well so so whatever try to
get him to sell to the to the Chinese
investors to make sure that there the
structure is very clean so would they
want to get rid of the VI structures
before you remember the pic rank between
the US government and Chinese government
about whether the legality of the VI
structure that's that's a non non issue
anymore it's not an issue anymore
because
the companies don't want it there
voluntarily giving up the VIU structure
to be able to list in the Chinese stock
markets even the company sets already
listed on NASDAQ a lot of them are are
trying to get privatized try trying to
try to delist try to get out to the
Nasdaq or an NYC a d-list and then move
back to China listening on Chinese stock
market because the the valuations on the
Chinese stock market just very very high
when you list you get about 30 to 40 p
the p/e ratio is about 30 to 40 and
after a few months you can usually get
up to around 100 the average p/e ratio
for the list of the companies around 60
today and still rising the average is
still rising so it's amazing so both
these companies like why would I want to
list on the NASDAQ and get about 15 to
20 p/e ratio when i get when i can get
60 p/e ratio on the Chinese stock market
and because the President Xi Jinping in
the present McCutchen is reforming the
equities market in China that perhaps in
the future that even the foreign capital
invests the company the VI e structure
can list unless a Chinese stock market
there they're considering the issue and
I take one step further maybe eventually
that Chinese stock market will allow
foreign companies to list on the Chinese
stock market so startups in Silicon
Valley can list in China because you get
much better valuation so more money for
Less dilution why not right so just like
when the Chinese company wasn't
listening us maybe in the future they
want to listen to China Chinese stock
market and raise money there in the
Chinese equities market so the
introduction of the third board have
gotten many more companies into the
power market very quickly instead of
getting a big PE round so China has went
ahead with very advanced reforms in the
equity
market is that the introduction of a
third board a third board is a board
that's even more aggressive than Nasdaq
because Nasdaq in China China has a main
board a trolley ban which is similar to
nasdaq now they introduce a third board
which compete with the Pease has a much
less a better bar to be able to list on
the third board so most of the companies
in China after the VC round today
they're not going for a Pyrrha they go
to public directly on the third board
because the valuations are much better
and you have less sofa because the the
you sure you get a big PE firm and
that's very bothersome to your
operations and you listen on the public
market usually you feel you have less
you feel freer on the public market and
China is considering a fourth board even
more aggressive you would lower bar then
the third board meaning that it's
actually going to compete with the VCS
so in the future perhaps that after
angel round after you do it for a while
you can get listed right away on the
fourth board you said we go into VC to
raise money you're going to just go to
the public market to raise money so
what's the fourth board is going to
compete with is most of these crowd
equity crowdfunding platforms because in
China right now there's a lot of equity
crowdfunding platforms but the
government feels that if it's allowed to
many of the private platforms to exist
then it will be highly unregulated it
will be probably going to be a mess but
perhaps the governor will be the biggest
crowd funding platform there is with the
fourth board so so perhaps there will be
no need for VCS so every everyone has to
evolve even the VC firms have to evolve
the investors have to evolve is this new
a day in an age so everything is being
disrupted today in the China's startup
scene so I said a lot of things that's
good about the China the China about
starting
company China but the last slide I
talked up to you about harsh realities
or starting come up companies in China
the competition in Chinese startup scene
is so fierce then every niche market is
filled with companies like I said
everything's been copied and every niche
market it's filled with tons of
companies in the US usually a niche
market has about maybe five six and most
ten companies in China every niche
market has over 100 companies doing
every niche every small niche you can
think of because there's so many
entrepreneurs working on everything so
the competition is so fierce that
everyone works extremely hard the cuz I
also invested in companies here in the
Silicon Valley right a lot of the
entrepreneurs in here in the Bay Area
they like to start companies in San
Francisco I asked them why they said
because in a Friday night you know San
Francisco you can go to bar chill with
friends on saturday and sunday so you
know you have a life I said you guys
have weekends here in China as a
start-up you don't have weekends and you
work a super late into the night because
the competition is so fierce and even
investors the competition is very fierce
I work extremely hard to fighting for
deals looking through companies so
everyone in China works extremely
extremely hard that's why when you
compare the companies here they devolves
so slowly but in China things move in a
much much faster pace as one example if
you look at the apple store right the
apps in the US and they have Guetta
updated about every two months in China
a nap get updated every two weeks you
see them you constantly have these apps
to be updated either in the app store
because yesterday just program me away
every two weeks to release the version
and they say that
oh my god you AB hasn't been updating
for over a month that's that's unheard
of when you do a nap you have updated
every two weeks at the bug fixes feature
the improvements product padding
improvements whatever just updated every
two weeks you kind of have improvement
every two weeks and that's the the
fierceness of the competition the
freemium model is not enough you see
they talk about the internet that you
give up stuff for free right in China if
you if you go out and give something for
free you have no market because everyone
give it out for free so you order to
compete you have to pay for users to use
your product you have to give them in
Chinese it's called home bah Fah hoom
bah it's called red packets for example
like it uber in the u.s. right you use
Hooper and they don't pay you to use
uber you know it's just you use it in
China even uber coming to china they
learn to give red packets at Weber gave
a lot of red packets to users to use
uber service so basically you right over
in China today is almost free and you
can make money to your by writing over
you can actually make money that's the
fierceness of Chinese competition that's
why you know how Chinese companies are
very competitive right if I hate very
competitive everywhere hopefully
everyone's working along Kusum hours and
you require constant fundraising because
you're giving away a lot of red packets
so in the US people talk about the burn
rate that will last about 24 months 36
months of burn rate after one round of
fundraising in China they talk about six
months burn rate you see so you're
constantly fundraising as the
entrepreneur so beside running your
business that's why these guys work for
longer hours besides working and they
have to fundraise all the time so you
need to know how to market and promote
really well since it's very difficult to
heard with so many people so many voices
so many noises being able to let your
product let you company to be heard it's
a very very difficult thing to do so
it's basically a jungle out there so
anyone wants to start a company in China
this is what's happening right lasted a
few days ago I had a in beta page
University where the dialogue was Peter
Thiel and we're talking about
investments in Silicon Valley and in
China and I was telling Peter that I
don't think you can survive in China
investing because Chinese entrepreneurs
and Chinese investors are alike it's
very very ferocious I use the word
ferocious okay I end my talk here oh
that's right Kevin thank you but I can
imagine there's a lot of questions from
the audience reabon will start go ahead
or any of these companies going to ever
be successful in time yes and well the
competition is fierce everybody is
developing the same product yeah they're
giving away maybe when I hit survive
just how do they survive the one that
can survive is a strongest wolf out of
the pack that's hot that's how these
guys succeed I don't know because of the
comics I imagine some are very good
teams wear a top quality entrepreneurs
but they got eaten there's nothing I can
do so the one that a dedicated survive
are the toughest ones are the best
actually I saw two hands first when I
were you so back in the back you and
then you in video okay oh yeah no you're
more of an expert than me but I'm
sniffing that I've heard this story
before in 1999 here 2000 when or
if or what do you see about the where
this goes continue forever or is there
some limit to the height of trees go to
the sky no I think it's a in the in the
short term short to medium term I
believe there will be a correction but
in the long term you will see that is
only a dip i legit look at will get
amazon stock price of amazon right you
see like this they will not like there
look at the only for the difficult red
figures here in two thousand perhaps but
it's okay but your remember remembering
facebook and all these companies are all
post-2000 right yeah even look at an
apple you look at who go if we look at
how much the entire internet has
transformed our world that entire
valuation combined of these companies
that that's only a dip that's right i'm
not come here to us because the bubble
will spread here as well okay well i was
a little bit of my question I wasn't
sure in your speech whether or not
you're concentrating on investing in
China or your investment here with your
angel fund a mostly in China but I do a
mess here because I invest in technology
because that's what I like I have a w
background and I you missed two areas i
invest in is one is artificial
intelligence smart devices and smart
life or smart everything and the two is
advanced pile sorry try the United
States working at now no because these
two countries all we've only two
candidates interesting sorry other
countries so based on why you said what
would be actually like the blue ocean
technology that you think will have a
breakthrough right with everyone smart
everything our intelligence okay is that
something that I would think the smart
intelligence will be something
reiteration and that seems to be that
what I don't know what what about what I
believe is that because if you look at
the AI technology that we use today it's
been around for decades right either the
sensor technologies the chips it's all
being around for decades
the reason why we're entering a new age
of the smart age it's because the prices
have been dropped significantly and it's
finally ready for mass appeal so that's
what i believe is we're going to enter
in a new age and the Internet age is
about age of information disruption
right we have seen that for the last 20
30 years of me 20 around 20 years of
internet development but right now we're
in the in the beginning of a new era or
new epoch is that um the age of smart
devices it's because they distribute the
intelligence and this is what I truly
believe so I'm invest heavily into this
area okay I saw a couple of hands over
here first can you know her I have many
questions but I get asked most little
later Oh what is a typical firm rate
that you typically see in China versus
what to promote our San Francisco ok on
the birds is uh no matter how much money
you raise you should burn it in six
months that's one foot right so if you
believe don't even up paying employees
you should give out red packets
customers will start with you another
one chinese company found wonderful mess
back on the local property in China
because the p/e ratio evaporation higher
but while it just mentally the Alibaba
and move our Y or go see not go through
Nasdaq was before that was before this
only this happy earth bob is only half
yeah half years ago wasn't this hot I'm
talking about changing very fast in
China so if I brought up in the go whoo
laughs Tyga happier gold he won't do
anymore uh I'm not a person had
political issues as well but I said it's
not a is morally exception than the rule
so I'm talking about more x alli Baba
so market continues Christian armies are
be listing on that back okay so you re
baba total in China's star market will
work more than now that's speculation
because it would in cannot speculate
what happens and I told you out about X
Alabama market look at I'm glad to hear
finally a eyes to a big show and I'm
interested do you have any focus on
which industries you think the way were
yeah yeah all industries we're gonna be
surrounded by intelligence it's an agent
distributed intelligence people talk
about the cloud you know with the cloud
technology with the Internet I don't
really believe in a cloud because I
believe in distributed intelligence
meaning that the intelligence should be
local around you rather than being the
cloud because with the cloud is not
responsive the latency you know with
Thea also the the reliability of the
college it will never be fully which
everyone would believe because the
transmission technology and networking
involved penetrating walls there's a
physical limitation to the cloud but
with distributed intelligence meaning
that intelligence will work around you
these chips being around you like the
SmartWatch although this is pretty
crappy rap I if Jobs was alive I don't
think it would release this but uh still
it's a start as we continue you go first
okay so hope you do I have a team of
developers in Ethiopia hmm and there's
an explosion of companies Chinese
companies in Ethiopia and eastern and
western Africa and my question to you is
do you think this climate of competition
has pushed the entrepreneurs in China to
look internationally and other
opportunities they have in celebration
as well in Vietnam me amar as well as I
Africa yeah
they're competing with the local local
teams yeah in those areas because
they've come with this aggressive
attitude yeah yeah yeah because their
genetic an awesome in China okay we're
gradually getting those white go ahead
of you first I met a complete loss to
understand where the real money is
coming from you see well that has been
hidden in China sufficient to set up the
VC funds the private equity farmers
email is your survival or source of
money Nick yeah yeah ah this goes into
the capitalism theory of how money
exists and how the government you know
create money out of the gdp you know
this is this is a long discussion money
just come out with somewhere right you
know the Chinese central bank creation
of gdp value increases you have pumped
into the market and cute quantitative
easing so we don't worry about that we
just see the effect okay I'm the
engineer I'm not physicist
what's our insight oh okay sure I'll go
to befall your daughter what is the
result I think I heard of incentive of
dream to sing chinese diminishing well
they are the for example the labors
aren't very expensive today compared
with yes and actually i heard that the
last year 2014 the small business they
start to take a very difficult surviving
pure and I could that's the reason why
the government is pushing trying to
support small pickle small business in
other policies coming we look at the
reasons of traditional industry is
hurting that's why a lot of unemployment
and a lot of college student don't get
jobs after graduation so the government
really want people to start companies
Christian is following or what for the
Chinese entrepreneur entrepreneurship
crew is the trend of slowing down no no
no it's increasing its increasing so
more and more people want to be
entrepreneurs because there's a India in
the Chinese Internet one of the
resignation letter was very popular and
they said um the reason for resignation
is that the world is so big I want to go
see it no i'm nothing to do with the
company you know i like it very much you
know nothing to do with the boss you
know you're very nice no it's just the
words very big obviously it so we're
continuing around on the stretch and you
first within us just talk seem to be
related to entrepreneurial and
technology that does that carry over to
new ideas for a fancy back scratcher or
a better-tasting soy sauce humbug via
the Premier Li coach Allen saying the
mass entrepreneurship he say
entrepreneurship anything you just you
can open up the small restaurant is
still gum from all set as well just
anything it's not just a high tag is it
Bumi just smut just didn't I tell ya
yeah
everywhere I first heard yesterday and
asked this question if everyone wants to
be an entrepreneur who will work for
them that was heard on TV I'm sure
there's many people one work for them
because I haven't and I'm telling you
that for example Chinese
entrepreneurship maybe risen to over a
million entrepreneurs right that's still
very little compared to the entire
population even that readily that's
durable they still need to learn
somewhere right oh yeah small business
exists for a large business exists to
marry the small business and more on so
it's where they learn again me the
promise with the quality people you know
the people who are the vice president's
you know that the directors these are
the guys leaving the company that's
actually hurts more than just regular
employees and that's happening
everywhere government-commissioned
technology now technology is adjust the
internet and you know software-based
what it how does it translate into the
medical technology could you elaborate a
little bit i'm back medical technologies
and there's some with the information
our revolution with the internet and
means transform the medical industry a
lot especially with big data especially
with also with smart devices in
distributed intelligence etc on the
medical side I'm not a expert on that I
said I a mess advanced biotechnology
it's more on genetic engineering and
these these areas I immersive right back
in the bad non-medical Wow huge projects
in this three to five years what do you
think will be the success rate
successfully in all the Chinese emperor
yes I think maybe ninety five percent
fail ninety-seven percent
roughly that's on I me feel less like
the HEPA costco shop about 5% a war
exists in law humanity but it's okay
because is you know why because in the
Entrepreneurship you never lose whether
you win or lose you want you want a
valuable experience right in your
lifetime and you're saying that is an
angel investor right yeah and your
people using your money yeah it's okay
because if you would say why in 20 right
if I if I us even your mandame yeah if I
get a 20 bagger yeah that's this break
even I'm obviously the winner is more
than 20 times yeah so you you play the
love the last game long go ahead you've
been patient okay you see that people
over there I walk along our and on the
weekend but also at same time a lot of
people have no job not as grant new
graduate and no job that's why
government as promoters are so white
wine keep just you and the other go
employee just over this hour we can the
higher war the most complete one work
that way right why because the more
people you have the more problems you
have people are not robots I mean if I
can follow up on that you haven't really
talked a lot about different
characteristics of different regions or
kind of you know the industry structure
because if you're right you know
knowledge workers are becoming really
expensive index cosines yeah so for a
while there was a big move come down to
the interior that was part of it comment
on that um well there's disparity among
the the country there is a disability in
price d the wages and the disparity in
loyalty to companies well there's a
there's actually two different parts of
China has a lot of specific
characteristics I'm just talking about
generalization today but if you go into
details about
guangdong companies they're the types
they their industry they like to be in
the type of organization they are
characteristics they're all very
different good my question is not
related to her presentation just related
to the how to try to motherhood well the
Chinese products that are marketed or
exported for developed countries and
develop content enough atoms of the same
static oh I can understand that that's
easy louder sorry the whole package I'm
not been quality aspect cause I samoas I
think the Chinese partner is the best
two batteries and one explodes you know
it's not easy battery with two batteries
it's a cheaper than the German what
battery so I think that a lot of early
China's growth was driven by the basic
infrastructure growth of the economy and
then really consumer spending has really
been an engine for growth and the last
maybe eight or nine years yes are you
seeing startup companies that are maybe
looking for yet another kind of growth
beyond that do you see them do you see
kind of different business plans now yes
yes yes consumer spending is way up and
also because the China is the biggest
market in almost every product category
for example cars China sounds more cars
today than North America and China sells
more cell phones than anywhere in the
world so that's why you guys talk about
the Chinese products in most of the
product categories almost all the
product categories china's markets
dominated with domestic products so
that's why there's so many chinese
products because actually for these
products the most of the markets
actually domestic for example phones
it's very hard to find foreign folsom
yeah right go ahead he's like 10 7 have
shut up Fieschi young boy you think they
can be 60
you think so because they paid hot
dollars and for these very high quality
startups and they came much higher
valuation for example I think Berlusconi
is gonna sell AC Milan and they got bids
for like say 5 500 million and the
Chinese will be like 650 and butter
cookies like okay she's all paid them
it's simple right I saw your hand first
okay yeah maybe you can address the
issue of intellectual property which is
kind of a veteran changing over time
because one of the issues that come up
with you know the last thing you guys
lately you're aggressive action yeah
electric car for patents patents are
difficult to enforce because it's it's
really a big arguments you know even the
US you know people fight patent all time
Samsung and Apple they fight each other
or with Google etc it takes over a long
time but with copyrights China's
enforcing that more and more if you if
you do a pirate pirate website you don't
have much many uh 11 of the parasites
are higher the website the CEO of that
got arrested for a long time hey Mark
dancer three months and copyright is
easily reversible Bob happens it's hard
to enforce anywhere go ahead I have the
same question relating specifically
state election you mentioned the editor
being online y combinator taking those
ideas and building a bunch of
competition without any protection at
all how are these companies is going to
be successful I mean once they start
young yet try me the domestic companies
I but you know how can the company
succeed with the web connections at all
what they've built in China actually as
the investors will look more for
execution capabilities rather than the
idea because an idea is actually very
cheap
because your idea will be copied
everywhere so why there's no value to
the idea there's more value to execution
capabilities actually I think you could
say the same thing around here here too
it's not really that well known but
people really care about you know the
track record as an indicator likelihood
that they'll do it the next time there's
a company Europe called rocket internet
and we got sort of that company it's a
copycat galore so they copy everything
from uber Airbnb to everything the scene
this is a European company yeah yeah and
they don't add that the joke is that the
only copy was popular in the US well the
Chinese copy everything matches up was
that not even popular gear next question
about companies in China do you keep
track of companies that do services for
the tech industry or maybe post tech
industry because the other a lot of repo
tech company the deal with furniture and
real estate and yeah how has that been
McGrath well there's people working on
everything well whatever you can think
of someone's doing start up on it back
in the back good I was wondering are you
concerned about cyber terrorism my cyber
you know disrupting things on a huge
scale I mean it seems so you know how do
competitors ever done seven you know
terrorists going after whoever mentor
like getting an atom bomb and explode no
mean because I wouldn't worry about the
the issue is too big for us to worry
about but if you worry about your
competitor hacking your site you don't
have to worry about that because it's
illegal to hack other people if you can
get evidence you can arrest or see or so
people I mean still yes you want to
compete right you know won't get
arrested so there was one thing that you
didn't mention in your differences
between 1999 and 2015 and that is the
existence of big private huh ya RAB
successful companies like Baidu and
Alibaba huh I'll have the big three
changed the landscape for startups in
China before right like a few years ago
they were a stranglehold for innovation
so like Microsoft and Google you know
they're like a stranglehold for
information here you don't like small
company they do very well and often
google that's something right cuz it but
um today it was a very bottom is that
all that item and then force you like
are you gonna sell you don't sell now I
have the copy cut here you know it's
like it's sort of like a forced sale but
um in China today in these couple years
recently because the mass of
entrepreneurship they don't have a
stranglehold anymore well the thing is
that even if you are lying you could be
eaten by the ants get there too many of
them I have to tell you that ten years
ago we had our jus mean who founded
WebEx yeah as one of our speakers in
this sounds and he said that china is a
jungle it is Silicon Valley is a zoo the
wild animals are here but they're all in
cages yeah so you guys surviving China
you can survive anywhere go ahead one
comment that I was going to make and I
really appreciate this picture that you
painted for us and that's that's
basically the change in the culture you
obviously promoted by the Government
Partnership the united states and their
didn't we weren't able to do this when
it's not even considered it's barely
considered necessary in DC right and you
are trying to do it they're trying to do
culture chic china's actually doing it
yeah they're actually impregnating and
entrepreneurship into the DNA of the
Chinese citizen yeah it's amazing what
the US is because of the political
structure here right and it's very
political there's two parties and you
don't every time just want to change and
and you don't even make
rule inch in the US has where the
coastal cameras the bill is going to be
changed a lot by the time it's that kind
of all the covers but in China it's very
fast dr. question go ahead which smells
you guys did you invest you know in the
Silicon Valley that you could not find
in China video hey I thought you could
find in Silicon Valley that should not
find shine unless a few companies here
one is called a Vemma fit which is a
number one smartphone bernas a
SmartWatch exercise app do a little ad I
was just meeting the guy this this
morning and also I invest in a company
called the impression pi which is the VR
AR with a full hand recognition glass
oh and also I us in cargo pal do
more ass it's a ski augmented reality
device for the ski Carlos all the way up
in Chinese companies right no no no I
thought on that if you're if you were
starting a company in the US you should
succeed in us first don't get my money
because you want to go to China because
I don't think you will survive there
just stay here stay here do well in the
US market do on Kickstarter do hawaii
indiegogo don't worry about China and
once you become big enough you can use
my resources to get into China but don't
get into there now because like her
mother doctor said your in your loo
don't try to get him to the jungle go
ahead so how do you see that big Chinese
companies now successful companies like
my huge incidents lets me succeed how
would they react to all these new
entrepreneurs basically won't be coming
up with new idea to disrupt them and
they two toilets are going to work with
one in Chile best others to buy them and
that's only two ways there's no way that
you can destroy destroy album and plus
the problem with these three Giants is
that many of their top people top
college people are leaving them to start
companies so that's the issue they
cannot
keep them
you